production designers take us to
beautiful new worlds the interior of a
spaceship the thing where a bear lives
an art studio in 1920s Copenhagen Tom
Hanks's housed a tyrants mountain lair
in a dystopian steampunk future tina has
been drinking but that should not take
away from the beautiful work of this
year's nominees for best production
design the nine Emmys are bridge of
spies production design by Adam
Stockhausen and set decoration by Rina
D'Angelo and Bernhard Henry the Danish
girl production design by Eve Stewart
and set decoration by Michael Standish
the Martian production design by Arthur
Max and set decoration by Celia bobba
the revenant production design by Jack
Fiske and set decoration by Hamish Purdy
Mad Max here
production design by Colin Gibson and
set decoration by Lisa Thompson and the
Oscar goes to Mad Max fury road
Oscar and nomination for Colin Gibson
it never ceases to annoy me how many
people it takes to make me look
competent so to get one of these you've
got an idea of the multitudes the
multitudes of Australians New Zealanders
Brits Americans South Africans Namibians
who all came together under George's
vision to bring you a tale about a man
with mental health issues
an amputee Amazon and five runaway sex
slaves so I'd like to chalk this one up
as the first Oscar for diversity thank
you can a man making the most amazing
food thank you